la librería de melisa que vende obras en
español y en francés en parís no ha
conocido tiempos normales abrió en
diciembre del año pasado en medio de las
huelgas por la reforma de las
jubilaciones y en marzo debido cerrar
por el primer confinamiento el 30 de
octubre al iniciar un segundo
confinamiento debieron bajar nuevamente
la cortina a diferencia de los grandes
centros comerciales las autoridades
consideren que una librería no vende
productos esenciales lo que se ve es una
desigualdad muy fuerte entre un modo de
comercio y otro modo de comercio estamos
privados de ver a nuestros amigos
estamos privados de ver a nuestra
familia estamos privados de ir al cine o
al teatro finalmente la lectura es para
mí una puerta abierta
este segundo confinamiento cariño está
sobreviviendo gracias a las ayudas del
estado y la instauración del clic en col
es un sistema de ventas a distancia en
que el cliente solo pasa a pagar y
recoger su encargos además la demanda
por literatura en lengua de cervantes
aumentó en un 10% muchos de nosotros nos
quedamos bloqueados sacar en general
viajamos
los países en el verano y esta vez no
pudimos hacerlo con mucha gente tal vez
se va a pasar un fin de semana en españa
se compra libros ahora como todo se paró
finalmente está en el hecho de poder
venir a comprar libros acá es una es una
buena noticia a wendy y una pandemia la
detiene abrió junto a sus socios una
tienda de productos colombianos en
octubre en pleno centro de parís sólo ha
conseguido trabajar a través de internet
confía en que se cumple los rumores de
una apertura el próximo primero de
diciembre o cuando tenemos la boutique
tenemos ventas todos los días tenemos
clientes que ahora son habituales y
tenemos muchos clientes que son nuevos
lo que por supuesto que es como la parte
que más nos conviene internet siempre
funciona bien sin embargo no hay esa
misma capacidad de venta es decir la
gente era te tienen que conocer para
poder ir a tu sitio de internet el
ministro de economía francés ha pedido
posponer en una semana la operación de
promociones puede navideña black friday
hasta el 4 de diciembre
finalmente grandes y pequeños
comerciantes podrán competir
de condiciones